en brasil 13 6 millones de personas
viven en favelas durante la pandemia han
sido los más afectados y al mismo tiempo
figuran entre los más beneficiados por
el korona vaucher el subsidio de 110
dólares mensuales creado por el gobierno
bolsonaro
barriadas siete de cada diez familias
solicitaron esta ayuda estatal para
hacer frente a la emergencia económica y
sanitaria
yo creo que esta ayuda ha sido muy buena
incluso yo la estoy recibiendo así
porque si no fuese por el subsidio la
pandemia podría haber sido mucho peor
podría existir un municipio en
septiembre un residente jair bolsonaro
alcanzó el 40% de popularidad el mejor
dato desde su elección muchos analistas
atribuyen el buen resultado a esta ayuda
financiera que ha alcanzado a 67
millones de brasileños hace 2 años
cain hará voto a bolsonaro hoy se
muestra satisfecha con su gestión del y
para él me trasmite honestidad el me
transmite una imagen de mano dura algo
que hoy brasil necesita
en 2018 el presidente triunfo en todas
las favelas de río de janeiro quien
conoce a fondo esta realidad asegura que
ocurrió por falta de alternativas un
entorno abandonado por las autoridades
este agente comunitario vaticina que el
éxito de bolsonaro no acabará con el fin
del corona voucher previsto para
diciembre
el crecimiento de su aprobación
continuará y no podemos olvidar que él y
su familia se ha convertido en una de
las más poderosas de brasil porque tiene
tres hijos que fueron elegidos
legítimamente
algo que le otorga un poder nunca antes
visto en el sistema político brasileño
el subsidio explica solo en parte el
buen desempeño de bolsonaro cuya forma
de gobernar es valorada positivamente
por la mitad de la población
jacqueline voto al actual presidente
pero dentro de dos años no repetiría y
eso a pesar de que el valor del subsidio
en su caso superaba su último salario
con este aumento repentino de los
precios de los productos en los
supermercados el subsidio nos favoreció
y al mismo tiempo nos fastidió ellos
están retomando esta ayuda de una forma
abusiva porque si das 220 dólares a una
persona de una familia con cinco hijos
como yo y después subes mucho el precio
del aceite no le estás haciendo un favor
a estas perjudica con bolsonaro llegó al
poder abrazando una agenda económica
neoliberal pero en los últimos meses
descubrió que una apuesta populista
puede propiciar la reelección no no voy
a quitarle a los pobres para darle a los
paupérrimos jones
para este politólogo bolsonaro es el
hula de la derecha por su facilidad de
comunicarse con el pueblo redujo los
ataques contra los periodistas y las
instituciones
optó por quedarse más en silencio
simultáneamente llegó el subsidio de
emergencia tal vez estos dos factores le
ayudaron a recuperar su popularidad
ronan es el fundador de derechas a un
gonzalo movimiento que reúne a los
conservadores de esta ciudad que tiene
más de un millón de habitantes es
importante que todos ustedes estén aquí
para conversar un poco sobre la derecha
este joven comerciante representa el
núcleo duro del bolsón arismo y ronald
es candidato en las elecciones
municipales que se disputarán en
noviembre hay una pelea para decidir
quién está más próxima al presidente y
quienes más bolsón arista
asegura que el éxito de bolsonaro se
debe a la gestión de la pandemia y a su
oposición a una cuarentena estricta
el presidente siempre alertó que no se
podía separar la economía de la cuestión
sanitaria
y ahora la oms ha cambiado un poco sus
orientaciones y ha acabado reconociendo
lo que el presidente dijo al principio
entonces las personas están empezando a
reconocer que bolsonaro tiene razón es
notorio que el factor religioso fue
decisivo para la victoria de bolsonaro
en brasil hay unos 65 millones de
evangélicos es decir el 31 por ciento de
la población de ellos el 70 por ciento
votó a bolsonaro
ese es el pastor de micheli bolsonaro la
esposa del presidente suele preguntar la
casa del mandatario a quien considera un
amigo en su visión el corona va a ser
explica sólo parcialmente la popularidad
de bolsonaro primero
miro bolsonaro está terminando varias
obras públicas que estaban paradas en
brasil desde hace años por causa de la
corrupción de los gobiernos anteriores
segundo la mayoría de estas obras están
siendo realizadas en el noroeste que era
el reducto de la izquierda izquierda
para la oposición bolsonaro no tiene el
mérito de unas obras que fueron
realizadas en gran parte por los
gobiernos anteriores
en noviembre más de 5000 municipios
brasileños tendrán que escoger a su
alcalde estas primeras elecciones
locales desde el triunfo de bolsonaro
serán un banco de prueba para testar la
fuerza real de un presidente que
sobrevivió al coronavirus en todos los
sentidos